,
dans la circonscription
d'un élu qui s'est montré
critique du premier ministre.
- Dans ce pub de Bolton, des
scènes de retour à la normale,
mais les souvenirs
du confinement sont encore
présents dans la mémoire
de certains clients.
"À un moment, on se faisait
dire qu'on ne pouvait rencon
qu'une seule personne
à l'extérieur", se souvient
cette électrice conservatrice.
Elle ne cache pas donc
sa déception d'avoir appris
que pendant ce temps,
des rassemblements arrosés
ont été organisés à la résidence
du premier ministre.
Si elle appuie malgré toutBoris
électeurs de la petite ville
du nord de l'Angleterre
sont moins indulgents.
"Les gens ont perdu confiance",
dit cet homme.
Certains demandent même
au député conservateur l
de forcer la tenue d'un vote
de confiance.
"Mettez quelqu'un d'autre
à sa place", dit-il.
Lors des dernières élections en
2019, le candidat conservateur
l'avait empoecececec une avance
de moins de 500 voix, mettant
fin à un règne de 22 ans
du Parti travailliste.
Un scénario semblable à ce qui
s'uiuiuiuiuit dans plusieurs
autres circonscriptions
de la région.
Ce coin de l'Angleterre
est surnommé le Mur rouge.
Pas pour les briques héritées
de la révolution industrielle,
mais parce que cette région
était un bastion travailliste.
Mais ici, la situation
économique s'est assombrie au
cours des dernières décennies,
une réalité sur laquelle Bor
Johnson a su capitaliser.
DAMIEN BOL,
King's College de Londres
- Il est vu comme la p
qui a réalisé le Brexit
en Angleterre, qui arrive avec
son lot de promesses de régler
l'immigration,
des politiques économiques
nationalistes en faveur des
entreprises anglaises et donc,
pouvoir potentiellement
préserver des emplois dans cette
région de l'Angleterre,
qui est encore assez pauvre.
(applaudissements de la foule)
- En 2019, Boris Johnson a ainsi
permis à ses troupes
de remporter la plus grande
majorité conservatrice
en 30 ans. Depuis, sa cote de
popularité a grandement baissé,
ce qui pousse certains nouveaux
élus à prendre leurs distances.
- Ils veulent simplement
continuer à être élus par leurss
cette assise qu'ont les autres
députés conservateurs qui sont
là depuis des années et qui...
qui peuvent se permettre de
rester loyal à Boris Johnson.
- Issu d'une familletrtrtrtrtrtt
s'était réjoui de la victoire
de Boris Johnson, un élu
différent en qui il avait
espoir.
"C'est juste un autre
politicien", constate-t-il
aujourd'hui.
Mais ce travailleur du textile,
favorable au Brexit, n'est pas
du tout convaincu qu'il votera
en faveur de l'o
travailliste lors du prochain
scrutin prévu en 2024.
Comme quoi certains débatspolis
à des personnalités publiques.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Can